when I was talking to Gregg last night I
noticed that he sounded horribly sick
and I did he says he feels fine but he's
still coughing and wheezing and hacking
so I'm making him where I'm making him
wear the mask to keep us all safe all of
us not just not just the people in the
studio people listening to this podcast
now let's go to Los Angeles where last
week the Rams beat the Seahawks but
probably the most noteworthy thing from
the game where was that two different
players Tyler Lockett of the Seahawks
and Brandon cooks of the rams went out
of their way to give a football to Floyd
Mayweather after scoring a touchdown
yeah Floyd medley way there was a in the
front row in the end zone and a couple
teams came and gave him give him
footballs one person from each team
scored a touchdown and gave him the
football Cooke said I go kind of track
the ball down so he could get it and
give yeah but it wasn't like he had to
run like he spiked it and I was like I
want to give him anyway I was pretty
cool I liked the Greg actually tweeted
about this and I think that I think the
actual tweet was giving Floyd Mayweather
the the football man zone is the touch
TD celebration of the year I know cuz I
like the tweet and then you deleted it
probably rightly so I almost never
delete any tweets but it felt like I was
trying to you know kind of make fun of
the situation but then you know the
nuance maybe would have been been lost
on some of the people it didn't didn't
seem worth I don't know whining anyone
surprised you know I mean you got you
got two teams playing football and then
you've got one of the biggest domestic
violence abusers in the world that we
know of sitting in the front row you got
to get him the ball you got to get
involved you know both teams have
domestic abusers on them of course they
do and yeah they're playing they're
playing a little hearts out giving 110%
but when he got Floyd beat up every
woman he's ever dated Mayweather sitting
in the front row you gotta get on the
ball you gotta feed him the ball either
team giving them the ball I think that's
what the NFL is all about especially in
November
Gregg what you have to say about that
anything about that so your theory here
is that even in a
field of athlete's foot in in domestic
abusers that you're saying
Floyd Mayweather it stands apart I'm
seeing the NFL more than any other
league values certain qualities and it's
in its athletes and domestic abuse
certainly seems to be up near the top of
the list
they've been I'm surprised they don't
they don't make it part of the combine
the way the league is going so when you
see Floyd Mayweather you gotta get him
the damn ball and that's what they did
Greg you chicken down by the way my
little more like menacing with this mask
on you feel like you can't see me
smiling saying over these things you're
like bang so listeners to the decimal
Nick and Rosenthal vanity project junior
vice president well know that last week
we really created a stir with our talked
about the migrant Caravan and okay the
election happened and it's been out of
the news but you know what the migrant
Caravan it's still it's still heading
north hasn't even slowed down
no it's opting for a safer slightly
different route now there was an update
on Tuesday but we've been getting a lot
of questions about but if anything I
think the Caravan sped up do you know I
mean they know we've been talking about
him and there were a lot of critics last
week saying we shouldn't have talked
about this but listen even though the
elections over and people when talking
about it we're gonna dig deep and we're
gonna keep talking about the caravan
every single episode until some of them
are in our government like until they've
reached that level we talked about them
if they could play in the NFL last year
over last week and you were saying they
would get crushed by other teams and I
think a lot of that was it was your
political bias but now that you've kind
of done a little deeper digging into the
caravan what are the chances the NFL
would expand the caravan I was like
because think about they were gonna have
a game in Mexico City you know that they
could be the Mexico City Caravan and
which is a better name than a lot of
teams out and they could turn around I
mean you're right I feel like the NFL
after taking this game it was supposed
to be in Mexico City the field wasn't
ready so now they're moving it to Los
Angeles they need to make it up to that
market turn the caravan around
start getting ready for 2019 does anyone
I mean does anyone else in the NFL think
it's hilarious the game was canceled due
to landscaping problems like no one made
a joke about that like that's that's the
issue guys get it together down there I
think that you know the NFL's about
money but I bet if you get these four
thousand migrants together turn them
upside down shake them they gotta have
some money on them pull that money
together you can buy yourself an NFL
team I mean they could they could be
like the Green Bay Packers only they own
themselves it's not just the city that
owns the team the caravan owns its own
team and we've been I've sent some
scouts out there to get some forty times
see what kind of vertical leap they got
but I think the caravan I think their
playoff team next year I mean but the
the NFL is all about merchandising you
know that's why they have every team as
so many different types of uniforms
what would the mascot be for the caravan
maybe just just an actual caravan I wake
some heads that's a you could not have
used your imagination less to come up
with the mascot for the caravan then you
just did great I think a crying baby a
crying baby would be the mascot almost
like actually is that the mascot of the
New Orleans pelicans they have the king
cake baby king cake baby yeah it would
be like that only darker I think that
would be a good like the huddle buddy
you tell me you wouldn't buy the Mexico
City caravans huddle buddy the NFL's
been looking for like a way to do kind
of a Developmental League ever since NFL
Europe has been gone I didn't know it
was gone
it's been gone for 20 years now okay so
you mentioned 4,000 people I mean that
they could maybe make a caravan league
unto its own it's not just 4,000 people
4,000 athletes in their prime that's
what I've been told I just think the NFL
is gonna get bigger and better and this
Caravan is the answer to almost all the
problems and listen let me tell you
something else I've been looking at the
comments on the videos people getting
upset yeah there's videos on YouTube of
to the podcast a lot of very upset
people people were yelling at me
forgetting about the politics let me say
this without involving politics
whatsoever
zero politics no red no blue no anything
if you were afraid of the caravan you
were small if you were afraid of
immigrants you were small if you were
afraid of women if you were a misogynist
you were small if you were afraid of
black people you were a small person and
you were scared don't be small America
is not small be big like me be I'm I
weigh a ton and I'm not
threatened or scared of any Caravan or
any woman or any black person or even
Greg's wife none of them
[Music]
you